[Music]
in conspiracy debunked news submitted by
Tim from Jacksonville hi Tim hello
Edward Snowden further discusses what he
found after searching the depths of US
intelligence networks American hero
Edward Snowden thank you she just did
one with wrote Joe Rogan two pockets way
to dumb it the [ __ ] down thank you
I like it thank you yeah Americans
connect okay so Edward Snowden former
employee of the CIA and contractor for
the National Security Agency NSA NSA he
had access to the nation's most closely
held secrets and when he was asked about
extraterrestrial life or you know other
intelligence he said [ __ ] yes for in his
book he said for the record I made a
detail as far as I could tell aliens
have never contacted earth or at least
they haven't contacted US intelligence
what the [ __ ] does he know thank you is
this cloud yes man really did land on
the moon climate change is real
chemtrails he's been paid off right
unbeliever threatened
wait what about Camp Charles chemtrails
are not a thing okay he says they're
just airplane poopoo it so everyone's
asking him about all the conspiracies we
went to the moon but did we land there
does he say that well he said the land
on the moon but how would he know so he
says that he had okay so he wasn't even
born at that yeah he's looking out the
files but the idea that we're hiding
them if we are hiding them I had
ridiculous access to the networks of the
NSA the CIA the military all these
groups I guess they're not ridiculous
enough yeah find anything
what about 9/11 and it could be hidden
it's hidden really damn well even from
people who are on the inside was he
looking when he was had access to all of
that
looking at everything apparently okay
Will Smith has real I was also he was
also a contractor he doesn't have all
the [ __ ] access to everything he's
not a pentagon Maddy what happened I
think you're on his side yeah but now
he's saying that all these aliens don't
exist and so now if I told you right now
and I need to defend my own says what he
says everybody wants to believe in
conspiracy theories because it helps
life make sense it helps us believe that
somebody is in control that somebody is
calling the shots that's why people like
religion is obscene it is Epstein a
conspiracy theory does he what would he
say about I've seen let me call them up
Edward it's only a conspiracy because
there's no conclusion if you want
something that makes sense you should
read the book holographic universe holy
[ __ ]
it makes yeah well I'm not them reading
it but then you could be what is it
about the simulation theory no I mean
kind of but not really let's not
simulation is that everything is a
hologram and our brains can process
these into interference patterns
everything's made of interference
patterns and that our brain is
projecting this whole reality the way
that we see it but really like if you
took it away it could just be a bunch of
patterns like this and like we as like a
laser makes a holographic image by
shining it on interference patterns our
brains are doing that to the
interference no so Snowden's a [ __ ]
hologram so I'm not gonna trust not
exactly you know what else is a hologram
I could have sworn we had 10 million
subscribers but we don't even have two
millions so we need to hit that mark by
people hitting the subscribe button
actually Joe you're projecting that
reality it could be at 10 million yeah
brain is listening so you don't you you
know what leave my longest criticism
about the SUBSCRIBE thing is that
sometimes a deal derails us and you
brought us right back thank you oh it's
awesome what do you believe in the law
of attraction yeah because of the
hologram theory no not because of that
but I mean I'm not through the book yet
but some of the ideas that I already
linked tent and desire for it's a lot of
religions like through scientific
research that they've done but like not
directly it wasn't like God and Jesus
and blah blah but it certain things that
happen it's like whoa that was because
of that like there's a we a prophet
there's always like the same kind of
things like reincarnation like that kind
of stuff
so they're all trying to make sense of
the same thing and souls and not like
actually doesn't talk about any of the
spiritual aspects of things but it does
explain a lot when you're like well that
if you connect the dots on your own I
just think it's one of those things like
slug bug right like if you're looking
for it then it's more taking up the real
estate on your mind so if you're
thinking of 10 million dollars
your mind is thinking of ways to obtain
that 10 million and so you're thinking
of deals and businesses and you're
immersing yourself same with being a
doctor or anything like your mind is
going toward that direction and you're
obsessively immersed in that world so
your mind is occupied that in that
direction but kind of but a lot of
Attraction also means you have to
vibrate on that same frequency as having
$10,000 you have to believe that you
could that that's possible you can't
look at $10,000 and go whoa that's crazy
I could never otherwise I want you don't
attract that because you that is law of
attraction because you're saying I could
never
so you're attracting that you could net
exactly you're just attracted a lack
yeah so your mind is focused on how you
can do it I want 10,000 you're
attracting the wanting 10,000 not having
10,000 am I supposed to be high to
understand what the hell you guys are
saying kind of yeah just be on our level
bar but it's okay you're on a different
frequency well in psychology the brain
can't tell the difference regardless if
it's a TV show or real life so if you
saw a murder in a TV show and you saw a
murder in real life the BRE can't tell
the difference well that's why when
people meet us in person they're like
whoa hold on like wait I know you you
know I'm small it's small it's their
same idea it says no no no it's the same
idea well yeah and they see you they
recognize you they don't quite know what
from but they're like wait a minute
you're real it's strange yeah great so
then that argument when parents are like
we got to get rid of all these video
games with all this killing cuz it's
polluting our kids - actually come true
no it's not true it's a thousand percent
sure [ __ ] because I've watched so
much porn I literally [ __ ] so many
guys and girls does not make any sense
at all you know same thing mind but you
know holographically is that like they
were even going into like if you touched
his bag like this yeah um
not even really the reality is and I'm
not touching your enemy my brain is
telling my my brain is telling myself
that I am having the feeling of
sensation it's a bad matrix I did it we
just watched it two nights ago I love
the matrix when he was a mistake he's
like I don't even cause it's not real
but my brain is telling me that this
tastes delicious and all this [ __ ]
that's the most delicious steak Sina
played ball move meat jam for sure no to
that slop jack real quick
Snowden Snowden so should he be
repatriated to the United States and
should he be declared a hero yep
I don't think he should be a war
criminal that's ridiculous what is that
what dude look what they're doing notice
on right now that guy's in a [ __ ]
dark prison cell probably in solitary
confinement probably never been proven
to be wrong about anything he exposed a
bunch of government [ __ ] that we're
doing yeah which we were doing and by
the way and he wasn't the one he
released information so the way that
WikiLeaks works it's like Wikipedia
right it's just WikiLeaks and then they
leak information so sources like spies
or whatever they have this information
they go they actually do the dirty work
and then they put it up on WikiLeaks
Julian Assange is the owner of WikiLeaks
and he allows the content he kind of he
kind of double checks and
cross-references the how relator like
how realistic this cop this this source
is so it's not [ __ ] and then when
it's ready it goes off
so is he verify it if it's anonymous
source no no his source is not so he
cross-references all these different and
make sure that it's real urban proven
Armani yeah but it was easy what it was
is the still alive think and we still
check that out WikiLeaks is still out
there yeah but but some people think has
been compromised because Assange is in
jail now yeah well I don't I don't know
they're still posting but there were a
lot of things that went up that helped
the American people but hurt the
government because of the shady [ __ ]
well so for example the spying operation
mass surveillance of our citizens which
is what Snowden also helped uncover
Snowden went to WikiLeaks with a lot of
us where all the TVs are listening to
and all stuff and that's been proven
that it was true yeah so you know trust
the government Manning - and Chelsea
manager stuff I've heard of all these
names and all these words but I just
just know that our media and our
government wants these people locked
away for a reason because they
threatened the war the brainwashing in
Washington so these people are heroes in
my opinion asked if we could just drown
Assange
can we just drown him and at the time he
was living in an embassy so in the UK
yeah yeah that's how [ __ ] crazy these
people aren't there although I can warm
up her own kill him yeah just a movie
and they want an it birds eye view of it
you can look that up so basically what
he did is he confirmed he confirmed that
there is aspect there there are branches
in the government that makes a ton of
money by basically destroying countries
it's always been a conspiracy but now
there's actual evidence
another thing that WikiLeaks exposed was
Obama had his whole cabinet hand-picked
for him by big company yeah and you can
see it all that's all any [ __ ] public
emails you can pull even how Bernie
Sanders got [ __ ] over during the
election from Hillary Clinton's camp I
was all weeks because of them man yeah
there's so there's a lot of crazy [ __ ]
down there down and they're doing it
again by the way the tulsi gabbard
yep they're silencing her there's all
this [ __ ] that's out what do you guys
think is stopping people from like
correcting it like do we not need
another agency that's strong enough cuz
it's almost like CIA FBI NSA they're all
like in cahoots with each other it's the
media
TIFF is plugged in to the media and she
doesn't even know about this stuff
because they don't talk about this stuff
from this perspective they're the Gabel
not like on WikiLeaks that follow this I
think there's a lot of things going on
like for one most people aren't
politically active or they don't care
yeah so most people care about how am I
gonna [ __ ] tomorrow how am I gonna eat
tomorrow and how am I gonna pay my bills
yeah I don't care that what war and
every other they don't give a [ __ ] and
there is a woke community but it's a new
it's a bigger newer I mean it's huge now
cuz the internet but they don't know
what to do and they don't know who the
real bad guy is yeah but thanks to
things like WikiLeaks this information
is out then the
can public can decide afterwards but the
difference is what we're being told by
the government in the freedoms that we
have and some stuff is just downright
illegal and unconstitutional so it's
violating the rights of Americans yeah
exactly
and I'm not talking about the government
here I'm talking about the Saudis did
9/11 like there were 19 hijackers like I
think all of them were Saudi Arabian
yeah maybe one Pakistani but the point
being who where did we go to war
Afghanistan lay in Iraq in Iraq right we
didn't go to no Saudi Arabia duh no [ __ ]
City USA even even civil lawsuits that
the that the 9/11 families want to take
against the Saudi government
we're disallowed for many years until
just recently bring it back down to
you're like why it matters to Americans
is because so like let's say our country
goes to war with the Middle East bombs
these people all that stuff right we're
creating terrorists solar air they're
just they're like let's say we've been
out there for over 30 40 years right so
they're growing up with our drones with
our military occupying their nation
blowing [ __ ] up they're like [ __ ] get
out of my country and then there's these
poor kids that are in doctrine into you
know Isis and things like that and their
lifelong mission is to kill us so then
if they get into our borders or whatever
they're not saying oh I hate you because
you're capitalists and you're American
they're saying you've been bombing and
killing my people for the last 40 50
years so it's time for revenge so that's
what Americans should think about and
worry about is because we're creating
these people that what Democrats said
ten years ago and now they don't say it
anymore right [ __ ] weird and because
the at the end of the day what's
happening is the war machine and the
money aspect of everything we could go
over there we could rob their oil we
could build our American companies we
can do a lot of things like what Bush
and Cheney did with Halliburton and the
oil you know he kept it going kept it
all going from the Bush Cheney years so
it's like what's the [ __ ] difference
and that's what allows so start to ask
so people like Tulsi Gabbard are like
well I don't want to keep doing all this
[ __ ] and even Trump is like I don't
to get out of Syria and then you have
people
both sides going you stay in Syria and
people tell them tulsi gabbard shut the
[ __ ] up or you're a Russian asset and so
there is a battle going on within the
government too it's not like everyone is
in cahoots there are people that are
like Tulsi and Anju who's more like
let's worry about America and keeping
this [ __ ] right because what's happening
is they're using the people so they
could keep rich in Assyria but he does
he protects Saudi Arabia like nobody
else and that's why what's crazy is okay
so to simplify it this is what's
happening they keep the American people
fighting left and right about issues
like LGBT things and that's what I see
the distraction it's a distraction
because what's really happening is
everything is a money grab at the top
and it's like let me [ __ ] fat in my
family's pockets and do all this stuff
keep it rich within my camp within the
camps so within the Republican Party you
have the bush camp you have these camps
or whatever in the war machine camp
right and those guys are like now it's
my turn I got my group in politics we're
gonna make all this [ __ ] money and
then who's paying for it the average
America with lies with our taxes with
our bailouts and that's where I think
people have to see the connection is
like everyone's in it for themselves
and it's not about you don't know how
they're being played by the media Dom we
know when we were real quick when we
were in LA every [ __ ] month there was
an anti-war rally while Bush is
President Obama gets elected the same
wars continue
no more anti-war rallies because the
media they forgot we were [ __ ] yeah
that's it man it's just all about what
the media is telling you be mad about
this week and you should look a little
deeper
[Music]